mit kippa es ist wirklich passiert leute
luca also adhs luca hat seinen song
gejobbt gemeinsam mit kasimir dem
deutschen rapper hat einen song machen
dieser song ist zu geil leute wir müssen
unbedingt reinschauen wir haben im
interview mit ihnen darüber gesprochen
hatte ich bin richtig gespannt wer
geworden ist kasimir und shampoo als o2
physik adhs luca 1 meter 50
ich glaube es einfach leid dass es so
krass alter wenn ihr das interview mit
luca nicht gesehen hat müsste ich das
reinziehen luca also adhs luca hat er
bei mir im interview gesagt dass er
einen karton mit kasimir was kannst du
uns dazu erzählen in die saison ist
jetzt draußen und sie sind einfach in
den bergen der ja das ist sogar das ist
wirklich einfach so eine geile sache man
fette schauen was wir einfach so auf
lukas du zuzugehen und mit dem er von
song zu machen finde ich einfach richtig
nice day
da muss man wirklich ich muss noch mal
bronze gehen leute es ist auch wirklich
so eine geile idee kommt da ist so
dieser moment es ist einfach ein
deutsches mim
und wie geil und einfach so holten so
alles passt zusammen ist es einfach so
ein deutsches team zu nehmen und daraus
einen song zu machen und zusätzlich noch
die person die das mit den new word
ursprünglich hatte nämlich luca noch mit
rein zu nehmen und einfach noch mal in
die berge zu fahren da ist es einfach
ist es eine geile wirklich die person
die das ausgedacht hat der creative
genius project ist das ist das ist der
gleiche bauernhof warte warte mathematik
das ist weder das ist wirklich so ein
anderes level
die sind einfach zum selben baum hof
gefahren wie krank ist das und ich da
war der hat den grad von 1 meter 50
jahren kannte auch untergeschoss durch
glaube ist für mich da raus aber selber
stelle einfach das ist wirklich also sag
mal schreibt mal unten in die kommentare
rein was war so ein moment sei es einen
song oder was auch immer der einfach so
gut zusammen gepasst hat die das hier
einfach an denselben ort zu fahren nicht
mehr derselbe ort ist exakt dieselbe
einstellung über hier sicher es ist
einfach eins zu eins schlechtere und
dazu kommt noch dass beide also ja ich
kann nicht so viel von kasimir aber ich
glaube er ist auch so ein rapper der
halt viel schreit zu in seinen songs
oder hat man muss eigentlich rein nennt
und deswegen passt sich perfekt mit luca
zusammen so ich glaube das ist auch mit
so ein grund warum dort zusammengefunden
haben
das wahlalter lz es steht an der wand
von dem gleichen bauernhof wo die vor
über zehn jahren die die focus reportage
gedreht haben hier seht ihr diesen schon
hier sagt roth unten dann silber oben
rotsee warum er steht litt wie an
demselben stand dass er das passt
einfach der das ist ganz ehrlich da
können sich also keine ahnung kann kann
sein dass irgendwelche loredana songs
oder was oder wer noch hinter loredana
auf 30 millionen klicks gehen das ist
das finde ich wirklich krass finde ich
auch gut von dem er seit sie an der
stelle aus die einst wieder 50 hohe
kante ist für ihn ganz klar ein ort von
dem man nicht runterfallen wird und da
muss ich wirklich sagen sehr gut die
sicherheit am arbeitsplatz ist ja auf
jeden fall gewährleistet die
berufsgenossenschaft die für selbige
zuständig ist hat an diesem musikvideo
mit sicherheit nichts auszusetzen was
gibt's besseres für den rap song als
wenn die berufsgenossenschaft damit
zufrieden ist
aber es ist einfach zu geil dass leute
das ist derselbe moment obviously ist im
moment aber auch noch die selbst ziele
nämlich in dem anderen video sagt trend
der auch weg als er genau diese
textstelle sagt und er geht der genau
die gleichen weg der bach das ist
wirklich zu krank alter das ist wie aus
dem weltraum so eine murmel werfen und
diesem umfeld aus dem weltraum genau
hier rein in diese flasche die in köln
steht so ist dass die galaxis zu krank
okay gut
jetzt hielt er der drogen talk wollen
wir jetzt an der stelle natürlich haben
natürlich ganz klar ein massiver
kritikpunkt verbleibt an der stelle
natürlich die erzieherin hat kein part
in dem song wo ich das jetzt gerade sehe
muss ich wahrscheinlich meine urteile
zurücknehmen warum sie jetzt hier kein
park bekommen hat dass wir nicht
wirklich krass das geht überhaupt nicht
kommentare sind auch leute elia vor drei
tagen bei soliden bekomme ich bock zu
koksen und meine oma aus dem fenster zu
schmeißen
das war auch glaube ich dass auch die
die musikalische intention dahinter dass
nach diesem song leute in deutschland
sich auf die straße begeben drogen
konsumieren und ihre vorfahren aus
gebäuden rausschmeißen
das ist der versuche gerade daran zu
denken also momente wo einfach so krasse
sachen passiert sind so richtig krasse
sachen einfach so einfach alles so
perfekt zusammengepasst hat das ist ja
auch nicht wenig arbeit so keine ahnung
und dreh zu koordinieren
zwischen kasimir zwischen luca dann die
ganzen sachen auch außen rum zu klären
weil ich vermute mal dass luca dann auch
irgendwie auf irgendeine art und weise
einem song auch finanziell beteiligt ist
denke ich mal von aus
wieder extra noch gebaut die rampe ist
die ein meter fünfzig hohe kante und
lukas ausrastern wiederholt sie weil er
an derselben stelle
zehn jahre später von dieser schnee
rampe da ein meter fünfzig tief gefallen
ist und dann kommt einfach derselbe
ausraster nochmal das ist wirklich so
ein rundes ding muss manchmal schaue ich
mal lukas was denkt ihr wenn man ihn in
dem moment hier erzählt hatte so prof in
zehn jahren in über zehn jahren wirst du
noch mal hier sein und du wirst hier
einen rap-song drehen der so heißt wie
der ausraster die du jetzt gleich hier
kicken wird in dieser situation damals
wird da muss er hatte damals weniger
bauens in seinem gang auf jeden fall
kann man hier so 2020 also bei uns auf
jeden fall jack aus so barbara aber
haben wir das also ich will mich jetzt
auch noch mal wiederholen leute ich
könnte das jetzt auch 30.000 mal weil
wir und ich das ganze ding finden und
wie lustig und witzig das ganze ist mag
auch sein dass jetzt besonders geprägt
bin weil ich jetzt vor kurzem erst mit
luther gedreht hat mich vor kurzem noch
so intensiven diesem ihn beschäftigt
habe aber viele von euch dass meine
zuschauer auch die minister gesehen ich
kann echt noch einen hut ziehen vor
allen leuten die an diesem mitgewirkt
haben ist einfach ist einfach so richtig
geile runde sagt ich weiß nicht das
letzte mal so eine runde sache gesehen
habe man die kommentare was ihr davon
haltet leute check hier einfach ich
vorgeschlagen für die objekte um ein
kanal und fällt auf keinen fall auch in
den nächsten tagen nicht von einem meter
15 kann und ich hoffe hier drauf
der strauß als gut
1 meter 50